[Music]
got another explainer for you all righty
this is one is on safe car accidents
okay i i'm i'm in the oxymoron so all
right i'll play along
okay
a safe car accident a safe
car accident correct okay okay so let's
look at the physics of a moving vehicle
all right so let's assume you're wearing
your seat belt so you're attached to the
car
all right you have all this stuff up
front
you know under the hood the engine if
it's a front you know front wheel
whatever front engine car right you have
stuff in behind you
you got the the the the doors to your
left and right
and nowadays we have airbags correct in
all those places okay the doors have it
the side curtain airbags are currently
everywhere right yeah okay so
the
only objective in a car accident
is to take the kinetic energy of the car
and
do something else with it
okay in a way that does not harm the
passenger the passengers okay all right
so
this is why you might have heard these
things about crumple zones right he said
why would i want to crumple my own damn
car because the energy of the speed of
the car
now goes into crumpling your car
because your car after the accident is
going zero miles per hour
right where did that kinetic energy go
it has to go somewhere someplace
something's got to break right you don't
want it going in your head in your head
okay something's gotta break
okay so
if you're not wearing a seatbelt and
you're going 60 miles an hour and then
zero
and if that happens relatively quickly
as what happens in car accidents you
become a bug you keep moving
so what happens is the car hits the wall
and the car stops moving right
but
you're not attached to the car
you keep moving at what speed 60 miles
an hour 60 miles per hour into the
windshield
correct now there are some people who
don't wear seat belts below like 30
miles an hour okay so i'm not going fast
enough i'll wait till okay
here's here's a thought experiment yeah
do you know how fast usain bolt was
running when he set the world record no
in 100 meters about 25 miles an hour
okay wow maybe 24 something like that
all right
so ask him uh usain please do this
experiment see that brick wall
run as fast as you can face first into
that wall
and then come back and tell me about how
to tell me how that went okay
so he would break his face probably die
uh yeah yeah and that's that's 25 miles
an hour yeah but at least he went out on
top
you know
my my favorite usain bolt plaque did i
tell you this no i was somewhat i was
somewhere in europe i don't remember it
might have been heathrow one of the
airports and there's a plaque there this
after he set his world record in the
olympics there's a plaque on the ground
and says um
right here in you know 19 you know in
2000 and whatever whatever was his
olympics 2012. um usain bolt
arrived at heathrow airport
his plane arrived 10 minutes late
that is amazing that is a really cute
plaque oh man oh yeah that was that was
good okay well i mean clearly you are
the fastest human period you're the
fastest if that's if they give you a
plaque a plaque a black that's fun a fun
plaque and plaques are always dry and
interesting this was a fun plaque but
that's
that's like muhammad ali and he was like
i'm so fast i'm so fast i turn out the
light and i'm in the bed before the room
gets done
[Laughter]
so you're going 60 miles an hour of
course the car has stopped and now boom
now you go 60 miles an hour and
energy goes as the square of the
velocity so you have four times the
energy as someone going 30 miles an hour
and you don't want to go 30 miles an
hour because just imagine usain bolt
running into a brick wall that way all
right right so the whole thing here is
you want to reduce the time it takes you
to go from 60 miles an hour to zero
right okay that's deceleration
a negative acceleration you you did i
say reduce it excuse me you want to
increase the time right because the
faster that happens the more damage
there will be to your body
okay
so
when dale earnhardt was in an accident
in the in the track and he was going
upwards of 200 miles an hour and hit
some embankment on the side
i think it was a one car cli i think
there was not there was no flames and it
just stopped
right i said he's dead
yes
because his body is going 200 miles an
hour and a right and a fraction of a
second later he's going zero
yeah okay
that's the kind of thing well is his
body strapped in sure but is his head
attached okay
your head is going 200 miles an hour
and it's just attached with some
ligaments and tissues and some bones and
that'll rip off your heart is dangling
there in the middle of your chest and
one of its arteries it's going 200 miles
an hour and in a fraction of a second
it's going zero this your heart punch
basically can can get ripped out of your
chest and not come out of your body
necessarily but
rip off of the part that's holding it
holding it up so things can happen
internal damage that'll just kill you
kill you okay so what you want to do is
you want to stretch out
as long as possible
the time it takes the car to slow down
okay
that's what you want to do
and while that's happening have the car
bear the brunt
of the the reduced kinetic energy yeah
let the car get
banged up beat up
let that happen to the car
let's just make the cars out of
marshmallows oh thank you okay and
that's kind of what airbags are are
marshmallows okay right so
not as delicious though okay so
when you do that
you reduce the stress on the body giving
your body a chance to slow down with the
car in a way that does not bring bodily
harm to you
okay
so
there is a video
on youtube last night some years ago
since i have no reason to think it's not
still there
and they walked
oh i get it this is a video
of the most twisted fiery
car wrecks
in nascar and formula one history
okay
and in every one of these wrecks
the person just steps out and walks away
while the fire folks come with the hoses
okay and they say and they walk and they
say it's a miracle
no it's not it's physics because every
one of those wrecks
the car went a quarter mile down the
track spinning twisting
bending
and there you are inside of it that's
quite the hayride you're on okay
but what kills you is that happening
quickly not happening slowly so the
longer it takes the more twisted the
wreck is for how long it took to come to
a stop and by the way they're all in
roll cages anyway okay all right so
let's get that straight so they're all
in a k in a protective cage let the
tires fly flames come out plus they're
in flame proof um uh suits zeus yeah
okay so what we're really talking about
here are are you gonna break your bones
so the longer it takes the the the
accident to slow down to a stop the
safer you are
period
and if you roll your car
and if you're if you're if your
hood doesn't completely crush in on you
if you know some of cars have ribs that
go around where the door frames are and
if you're wearing your seatbelt
if you run right off in a bag and your
car rolls down
and all right
that's what you want coming from 60
miles an hour right that'll do it just
stretch it out stretch it out stretch it
out
okay so i i've heard of police who've
come up to and they see how banged up
the car is and use that
as evidence that the person should have
been hurt badly
when the more banged up the car is
provided the kate the cavity where the
driver is is still intact right
the rest of the car let it get banged up
that's what you want in order to absorb
all that kinetic energy
that's what i'm trying to say here
so and by the way that's why
high jumpers
and pole vaulters
land in pillows
and not on cement well yeah
okay
if you come over a high jump or a a a a
pole vault and you fall down
gracefully backwards and you hit
cement
you just broke all your ribs and your
back
okay because they actually instituted
that about five jumps in but yeah
the five guys that didn't make it
so you know we should put some
some should go under here guys
guys i'm not going next
question
why did you think it took five times
there's some physics idiots there
so you want to stretch out the time so
the
the deeper that cushion is the less
injury there is and there's so little
injury that they get back up and
continue all right they don't have to
like go to the hospital every time that
happens
yeah that's like when they shoot the guy
out of the cannon and
uh they shoot them into
cardboard boxes empty cardboard boxes
that have all been stacked on one
another oh okay yeah and so each box
just well my god my guy got shot into a
net
did you go to the budget circus
the trash boxes listen i went to a
ghetto circus okay that's what i'm
saying
it was very my people had nets i don't
know where you were
go get some boxes
[Laughter]
because the net of course when you hit
it right it's not rigid it'll it'll
absorb your energy
into the
um
into the framework of the stitching yeah
but it also may throw you back out boxes
so whenever so what happens is what that
meant is it didn't completely absorb the
energy okay well it takes the energy and
it sends you back out the other way
correct so the energy bounces that can
happen
okay
so so anyhow with a car you you want
this it's why head-on collisions are so
deadly because the car doesn't have a
chance to slow down
right and the whole point of the airbag
is to give you a chance to slow down in
a very abrupt front-end collision
all right so the airbag will get there
before you will because it expands
explosively
it moves at the speed of sound basically
when it
inflates and that's faster than it would
take you to actually hit the dashboard
because your car is not going at the
speed of sound in the other direction
right so the the bag beats you
to
the collision you would have with the
windshield or with the dashboard and so
and then it's basically a marshmallow
so that helps
because it's soft and it's cushiony and
it
increases the time that it takes you to
come to a stop
your body to come to a stop so a safe
collision is the one that takes the
longest provided your your your
your driver space is not compromised so
when they say it's a slow-motion car
crash that's actually a good thing it's
a good thing that's a good thing so
that's all that's all i try to say here
well i think the the lesson here that
we've all oh and one other thing a
different train
that's the real lesson here the train is
the way to go
because
even if you survive it you really don't
want to be on that highlight reel is
what you're saying right that's not the
thing
all right so here's something to look
for
maybe we could put this in a in the
sports edition
um if you ever want to know how badly
hurt
the batter is in baseball if they get
hit by a pitch
right look to see how much
the direction of the ball changed after
it hit them oh
okay
right so if it hits their thigh
but keeps going and gets caught in the
catcher's mitt oh
not a problem right okay it'll sting but
it's not okay
if it hits the thigh bounces forward
oh my gosh because that man all the
kinetic energy of the ball got absorbed
by the muscle and the bone and got sent
back so watch now that we have it all in
slow mo high speed cameras you can see
what the exact trajectory of the ball is
right and the more the ball continues to
roll back to the backstop or go to the
side or go forward is the full
information you need about how much
damage it would have caused the batter
and if you don't see that you know that
how much it hurt when the batter rushes
the mound to beat the hell out of the
kitchen
that's when you know it really hurt
plus there's another thing with bat with
baseball you know it's it's not a
violent sport yet if they get hit by a
pitch they they're not going to rub it
right right
they're tired it's on
they don't want to show the bat the
pitcher that right that the pitcher hurt
them yeah they walk it off as they walk
it off exactly and they're not even
going to rub the spots they got too much
pride so
so imagine if they were world cup soccer
players
oh my god
if you hit a soccer player with a
baseball he would just fall down i'm
oh god
and i broke it now
[Laughter]
no they always hold their knee or their
ankle right even no matter what the
academy awards for that anyhow that's
all the time we got chuck all righty
all right so hey so like i said anytime
you you see one of these accidents if
someone says it was a miracle no it's
not it's just physics
it would have been a miracle had dave
dale earnhardt survived
the uh his crash oh and one other thing
there's a record for the person who
survived the highest fall from a
building
all right now there's a height above
which basically 100 of people are dead
this person fell from a higher fight and
survived
and they say they credited the person
was religious and jesus saved them or
whatever but if you okay i heard this i
said i need more data here and then i
looked at the building the person hit a
tree
on the way down gotcha okay and broke
branches of the tree oh that's a good
thing because the kinetic energy of the
body is now going somewhere else
rather than breaking his own bones and
probably broke his food bones
nonetheless
but in a fall that would normally kill
you if a tree is there it's going to
help you not die
anything that's in the way is going to
help you not die so all right chuck
that's all we got for this experience
what kind of car accident to have to
maximize your chance of surviving it and
don't ever run full speed ahead into a
wall please uh too late for that
you don't have to tell me twice i'll put
it like that all right
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure neil degrasse tyson here keep
looking
[Music]
you